- So I'm at Eurostar, I was thinking about
what lightning talk I'm
going to do this morning.
And yesterday and a couple of days over
the conference I've been getting certain
questions coming through.
So what I'm going to talk about is
what testers can do and an easy way
on Agile projects to help themselves.
I will stick the timer
on for four minutes,
I'm going to work from my notes
and we'll see how far I get.
So generally what I'm asked is,
"Our Agile project is
screwed up. What can we do?"
And I do get asked this a lot.
LinkedIn, various other places, a couple
people at the conference have asked.
And what screwed up means,
we don't have any time for testing.
By the testers.
We've got no time for
automating, again by the testers.
People are not skilled
enough doing the work,
we don't know how to test this.
We've got no acceptance criteria.
That's good enough for the testers.
There's no story and details,
we don't invited to meetings.
And again this is all tester related.
It's not that these
things aren't happening,
it's just everything here
is related to the test part.
And the problem here is that the projects
themselves are not Agile.
They're calling themselves Agile.
They use Agile words,
they have Agile rituals
in there: retrospectives,
stand ups and three amigos
whatever else but there's
no agility in there.
There's no attempt to continually improve
and refine the system.
So we have roles and
subsystems and testing,
anything with testing it
is done by the testers.
This is a problem.
Now, we have to keep
fighting the good fight
which is explaining what Agile is,
explaining what testing is within Agile.
But we also have to deal with
the actual reality we face.
So some tactics for doing
that are first of all,
control the things that
you have control over.
Right, so get your own house in order.
Make sure that you have the
skills to do your testing.
You've set the expectations you know what
expectations people have
and you've agreed them.
You avoid waste in your process.
You're not writing big test plans.
You keep things as lean as possible.
Keep things documented
as lightly as possible,
at the point that you need it.
Keep it lean, and keep control.
Own the things that are yours to own.
So own exploratory
testing, and do that well.
Make sure you do your exploratory testing,
you write down your plan of
what you're gonna attack.
That way, if you use Agile words like
done and not done, when you've got a plan.
When people come to say
"This story is done."
and see that your testing
has got all the stuff
that's done with all the evidence
and all the steps that you took.
But it's also got these
things that are not done,
'cause you haven't had time.
It's harder for them to ignore
that there's a problem.
'Cause that feedback is
staring them in the face,
and they have to act on it.
So make sure that you're writing down
the things that show the scope,
that show the effort, that show the work.
Make the testing visible,
but not just make
the testing visible make the testing
visible such that it
acts as negative feedback
in the process, so they know where
the pain points are for testing.
And this one is key and
slightly more controversial.
Which is, don't do the work of others.
Right, 'cause very often what happens
is if you give an inch they'll take a mile
and they'll keep taking the mile.
So, if you don't have enough time to test,
that the software story is
delivered at the end of the day
the testers might stay
late in order to test it.
To provide the feedback
so that programmers
can work on it in the morning.
Don't do that.
Right, you're doing somebody else's work.
You're absorbing their
failure in the system
and taking it on board.
They way they have no pain.
They've got no negative
feedback causing them
to change the process.
Do not, absorb the work of others.
Don't do the work of others.
If we've agreed as a team,
that everyone is going
to do automated execution
and build test code, if
that's what we're calling it,
then don't do that on your own.
Bring people in and keep reminding people
that we said we were
going to pair on this,
can we pair on this
now, can we do this now.
Keep pushing for that, make
opportunities for it to happen
but control your part of the process.
You don't attempt to fix Agile,
you attempt to fix the bit
that you were involved in.
(alarm)
So that's four minutes.
So I didn't quite cover
everything I've got written down.
Other things I've got
written down, not much more.
Part of the issue is,
when we absorb other
peoples parts of the process
we then can look bad because we are doing
what we think it takes to make the project
keep going on, but we're
getting enough time
to do everything that we want to do.
So we're not getting a chance to do
all the testing that we want to do
because we're trying to do
some automating as well.
We're not getting the chance to do all
the automating because
we're doing the testing.
We're refining the stories late so we're
having to go have meetings
about the acceptance
criteria to figure out
what we need to test
after the story has been played.
Which then cuts into time that we could be
using for testing, or automating.
And the fact that we're absorbing all this
makes the project look good.
Makes the project run more
smoothly, which is important.
It makes us look bad, and makes testing
look bad on the project
because we're trying
to do our best.
And sometimes we have
to let the system fail,
by fitting in with sustainable pace.
Whatever is its 37.5, 40 hour weeks.
To keep things on track,
but to make visible
what we have done and not done.
'Cause it's negative
feedback that causes change.
I was thinking yesterday,
that a lot of this
is coming from cybernetics
when I think about it.
In terms of, we talk about
feedback a lot in Agile.
So we have retrospectives,
we have standups.
We have lots of interface
points that we're
looking at feedback in order to come in.
But then I realised yesterday,
it's feedback in the sense that it's
an output that comes in as input again.
But, if the input is not processed
it makes no difference.
We say we're going to do certain things
we have these goals that
comes in as feedback.
If we don't act on it, it's irrelevant.
We've filtered it out.
It's not impacting the process.
It doesn't cause the process to change.
Which is why in retrospectives you
don't just come out with goals.
You come out with the next steps.
And you do the next steps.
And then you can remind yourselves
during the actual sprint
about those next steps.
Have we done this?
You can do that in the standups.
When are we going to do this?
Do you have time today to do this?
You can covert them into stories
to make sure that you do them
'cause they're on your board.
There's steps that we can
take to make things visible,
and make it actionable.
That systems, only change when they have
negative feedback coming
in that's processed.
Very often what we have
is negative feedback
that comes in that is filtered out
or, and this is what often happens,
to tester absorbed by a
single part of the system.
So negative feedback comes in,
that we don't have enough
time to do automating.
That gets absorbed by the test part,
so no one else gets
involved in the automating.
Test part then has to work longer hours
or weekends to try and get this done.
Or it becomes testing stories that
never get finished, they
look back, they look bad
that part gets absorbed
by the testing part.
And it shouldn't, an effective system
doesn't have subsystems
absorbing negative feedback.
Particularly when it's system feedback.
And most of the feedback
on an Agile project
is system level 'cause it's the system
that has to change, it's
the way that we develop.
It's the way that we work as
a team, that has to change.
And until that feedback
get absorbed as the system,
the process doesn't change.
Which is why its hard for individuals
to fix it because individuals
take that feedback
and absorb it on their own.
Now ideally, in a four minute talk
I would like to mention that as well
but then people have to understand
the notions of cybernetics.
And I'm concerned that people might
not understand cybernetics or feedback.
So I'm going to talk about it more
general clear actions steps you can do.
To me that's coming from the notion
of cybernetics and systems
viewpoint of how people work.